والبدايه من بريطانيا حيث بدا العد
التنازلي لحفل تتويج الملك تشارلز
والمفاجاه هي ولاول مره باتت زوجه الملك
كامله تحظى بلقب الملكه قصر باركينج هام
كشف عن بطاقه الدعوه وجهت بشكل رسمي
لالفين شخص لحضور حفله تتويج في السادس من
مايو المقبل وبالتحديد في كنيسه
فالعائله الملكه نشرت في نفس الوقت صوره
جديده تجمع الملك بزوجته كامله او الملكه
كامله مثلما تم تعريفها في الدعوه الرسميه
حتى الان من غير المعروف اذا كان الامير
هاري وزوجه اوميغان ماركل سيخدران حيث
تلقي بالفعل دعوه لحضور مراسم هذا التجويج
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ايضا لن يحضر
حفله تتويج لكنه اخبر الملك عبر الهاتف ان
السيده الاولى جل بايدن ستمثل الولايات
المتحده في الحدث المنتظر
[موسيقى]
من الملاحظات المهمه في دعوه حضور حفل
تتويج ملك تشارلز وهو استخدام لقب الملكه
كاملا بدلا من عقيله الملك وهي اول اشاره
رسميه وتمهيد لتغيير لقب بحسب مصادر ملكيه
كان من المنطق استخدام اذا لقب الملكه
القرين لتمييزها عن الملكه في فتره ما بعد
وفاتها مباشره لكن بعد تتويج سيكون الوقت
مناسب لتغيير لقب رسميا الى الملكه كامله
الدعوه ايضا تعكس اهتمام الملك تشارلز
بالبيئه فهي مطبوعه على ورق معاد تدبير
نزيف وهي مزينه باوراق الشجر الطبيعيه من
البلوط واللبلاب والدعوه يظهر فيها شخصيه
رجل الاخضر من فلفلور البريطاني القديم
الذي يرمز للربيع والبعث فهي اشاره لبدايه
لعهد الملكي الجديد الابناء والاحفاد
سيحصلون على ادوار خلال المشاركه في هذا
الحفل منهم الامير جورج ابن الامير وامير
تويلز ويليام وكيت وايضا ثلاثه من احفاد
الملكه كاميرا